>> WHEN YOU GET OLDER, YOUR BODY
PRODUCES A LOT LESS
TESTOSTERONE.
AND THAT EFFECTS EVERYTHING THAT
MAKES YOU FEEL LIKE A MAN.
AND YOU KNOW SHE CAN TELL.
BUT BEFORE YOU FACE A FULL ON
VITALITY CRISIS, YOU FIND
TESTOSTERONE BOOSTING SUPPLEMENT
ON TV AND YOU KNOW IT'S
EFFECTIVE BECAUSE IT'S IN A
GIANT BLACK CANISTER AND
ENDORSED BY THE STRONGEST
RETIRED ATHLETE MONEY CAN BUY.
>> GET YOUR BALLS BACK.
>> YOUR SOUL.
>> AND BEFORE YOU KNOW IT,
YOU'RE A BRAND NEWMAN.
YOU'RE RUNNING FASTER.
TRAINING HARDER.
AND LASTING LONGER.
YOU DID IT, HOS, YOU ARE A MAN
AGAIN.
ONLY ONE PROBLEM.
YOU'VE TURNED INTO A FULL
PSYCHO.
LOOK AT YOUR SELF, MAN.
YOU'RE WEARING SKIN TIGHT MUSCLE
SHIRTS TO WORK NOW.
YOU'RE IN YOUR MID-50s WITH JET
BLACK GO TEE.
THAT'S NOT NORMAL.
YOU THINK IT'S COOL PORNO YOUR
WIFE, SHE HAS OSTEOPOROSIS, YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT FEELS LIKE WITH
HER?
CRACKING EGGS WITH A HAMMER.
AND NOT GET INTO THE INTERN YOU
ARE FREAKING HER OUT.
YOU DO REMEMBER YOUR WIFE,
RIGHT?
THE ONE ON THE COUCH ICING DOWN
HER SHATTERED PELVIS.
SHE NEEDS A BREAK.
ALL THAT EXTRA TESTOSTERONE HAS
MADE YOU AN AGGRESSIVE ALPHA
NIGHTMARE.
THAT'S WHY YOU NEED BETA FORCE.
THE ONLY SUPPLEMENT THAT CAN
COUNTERACT AND UNDO ALL THE
OTHER JUNK YOU'VE BEEN TAKING SO
YOU CAN BE A REGULAR MIDDLE AGED
MAN AGAIN.
WITH ODORLESS, TASTE LESS,
COMPLETELY UNDEPARTICULARABLE,
BETA FORCE.
BEFORE YOU KNOW IT, YOU'LL BE
BACK TOUR OLD SELF AGAIN.
>> I LOVE YOU, HONEY.
>> OH, I LOVE YOU TOO.
THANKS, BETA FORCE.
>> WHAT'S BETA FORCE?
>> HUH?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]